was geht ab und herzlich willkommen tour
und ein video ich hoffe natürlich jedes
gut weiß hier meine letzten - verfolgt
habt was ich natürlich sehr hoffe wenn
nicht dann müsst ihr das jetzt nachholen
bitte danke ich war letztens in berlin
bei dahin und patrick die haben dort
auch ein relativ großes retourenlager
und da ist noch oft bei ihnen kam es
dabei wo ich mir dachte da kann man auf
jeden fall dass eine andere video zu
drehen ich hatte schon öfter mal im kopf
so fernseher zu bestellen also retour
entfernt das gibt's ja auch viel bei
ebay aber irgendwie war da immer nur
schrott dabei und manchmal dachte ich
auch dass der absolute aber jetzt beim
daniel da habe ich was gefunden und ja
hier ein kurzer ausschnitt durch sein
oder also die könnte ich jetzt auch für
600 nehmen und praktisch zu kaufen aber
ich kann mir auch ganz ehrlich sagen
meisten dieser fernseher die kriege die
haben alle größere defekte ich glaube da
wirst du also würde ich jetzt nicht 600
euro zwei monate ferien für seine
fernsehballett fünf fernseher drauf sind
maximal pro fernseher 30 euro jährlich
so günstig sind günstig und du kannst
glück kam dass da einer drin ist er
schlecht und ich starte dann machst du
ein bisschen was ja repariert es in der
warnung davon hast ja da kann ich
richtig geld damit können wir das so
machen dass du mir wirklich so eine
palette zuschauer zu diesmal ja also
wenn da müssen wir den ich hier auf
mache dann mach ich dir lieber in meinem
büro auch dann sagt mir direkt was
nimmst du dir ich will dich ja nicht
abziehen sachen guten preis dann seine
palette fernseher 120 20 euro trinkgeld
okay dann schickt sie mir die tradition
kommt ja auch noch drauf heute morgen um
9 uhr kann man hier ein lastwagen an und
ich habe die fernseher entgegengenommen
es war 140 kilogramm fernseher die ich
ihr heute hoch gestellt habe alleine
durch einmal hinstellen und den rest war
ich dann
[Musik]
hey leute ich bin so am schwitzen ich
habe gerade gemacht ich habe gerade auf
jeden fall die ganzen fernseher
hochgetragen waren 140 kilogramm jetzt
geht's erst mal nach hause duschen und
dann war ich später wieder jeden und
gucke mir die mal genau an daniel meinte
ich muss mich nicht wundern dass sie
wird höchstwahrscheinlich alles defekt
seien kurz noch vorweg ich habe pro
fernseher glaube ich 35 euro bezahlt
muss doch mal 100 euro speditionen also
insgesamt jetzt 300 euro aber für fünf
fernseher kannst du echt glaube ich
nicht meckern allein wenn ich den
eigentlichen sehen eine ahnung der
kostet 2000 euro dann würde ich sagen
statt man mit dem kleinsten oder also
könnt ihr sehen leute das ist der erste
fernseh wir einen sony bravia xrx 9 j 75
zoll und hier hinter mal kurz wobei ich
glaube das habt ihr jetzt morgen auch
schon auf den aufnahmen gesehen sind
noch so ein lg fernseher keine ahnung
was der werte sachen lg nano cell
fernseher im philips fernseher und hier
hinten haben wir noch ein samsung
crystal ultra hd er kommen da nachts ist
geschützt display geht nicht an keine
garantie das ist schon mal ein
schlechtes zeichen ich brauche definitiv
irgendwie ein größeres büro aber habe
ich auch bald weil so langsam geht mir
hier der platz aus erst gar nicht lachen
der kann richtig dass flöttl sein denn
hatte zu hause hat fifa verloren habe
seinen controller rein gepfeffert und
jetzt ist er hier bei mir gelandet das
ist eine wahrscheinlich würde sagen die
mache ich das jetzt am besten macht ihn
einfach mal auf also es ist wirklich mal
wieder ein spannendes neues projekt für
mich was habe ich ja jetzt noch nie
gemacht hugo mallet
dann macht es besser so jetzt ist auf
jeden fall defekt
gott das war wirklich sehr dumm es tut
mir leid also echtes muss ich auch nicht
wundern warum einmal leute kommen hier
wie du mich eigentlich bin ja hier so
und sehr gut eingestellt hast du auf ja
wobei man sieht hier schon leicht ich
weiß nicht ob es auf der kamera gut
rüberkommt aber hier sind schon so ein
paar komische als werder wasser
reingelaufen und hier ist der bildschirm
des komplett gestreut dass dingen kannst
du eigentlich turnaround leute also bei
dem bin ich mir sicher er wird nicht
angehen 1000 euro drauf wetten einfach
mal hier die füße dran aber
so
wieso bin ich denn so dumm guter sicht
ich hatte hier ein schöner ultra hdtv
steckte man mal ein es sei leider ist
die fernbedienung bei ja ok er wird aber
nicht angehen oder also tut sich was
kann man da was sehen alter ja ok denke
das kann man reparieren glaube ich nicht
lohnen so etwas zu reparieren das ist
bestimmt ich kenne mich damit fernseher
reparatur nicht aus scheiße also was mit
dem passiert ist würde ich gar nicht
wissen funktioniert schon mal nicht
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten weiß
ich was mache ich mit den dingern dann
als nächstes haben wir hier einen
wunderschönen es muss ja nur ein
fernseher funktionieren wenn ein
fernseher funktioniert dann bin ich
nicht reich aber das hat sich dann halt
übels gelohnt und das wird klappen sieht
auch wiederkommen die kommen so an als
wäre dann hätte die noch nie jemand
zuvor auf gemacht hast du wieder die
erstmal hier ne genau erst mal schluss
jetzt ja genau das dann machst du so
vorsichtig nicht so wie gerade guck mal
der ist doch und dabei kein zettel dran
defekt nein der ist auch defekt oder
guck mal da wird genau das gleiche mit
sein egal wir machen trotzdem mal an ich
schreibe ja keine schrauben fest an den
defekt gefährden ist der quattro
was meinst du kostet dann so ein
defekter fernseher also ich kann mich
natürlich mal umhören lassen bei einem
fernseher reparateur ob man die
reparieren kann und ob sich das lohnt
aber ziemlich sicher dass sich das nicht
lohnen wird aber leute da muss ich
fairerweise auch zu sagen das hat ja
daniel direkt gesagt alex macht ihr
keine großen hoffnung habe ich auch nie
gemacht aber ist er trotzdem interessant
weil der ihr wird funktionieren
scheiße mann ist eine windmühle ist
wieder alles defekt
ja das also was soll ich damit kurs
machen wir haben gar nicht gecheckt was
die wert sind mache ich mal eben also
der samsung kostet alter der kostet
einfach neue okay da ist dass der 43
zoll kostet neu 120 euro hätte ich jetzt
auch nicht mit mehr gerechnet der hier
liegt neu bei 700 meine ich habe ich
eben nachgeschaut ich habe den hierfür
680 aber naja ist auf jeden fall jetzt
nicht so viel sogar gedacht dass hier
mehr kosten aber der inhalt jahrhundert
der andere ca 600 in ihren beide nicht
haben können wert mehr weiß nicht
vielleicht irgendwann zwischen 30 und 50
euro genau kann ich nicht sagen ich
kenne ich mich nicht aus aber wir haben
ja noch drei mal angenommen keinen
fernseher funktioniert bin ich natürlich
also dann irgendwelche bastler kommt
vorbei denn einfach alle wieder mit weil
die stehen nicht nur im weg aber
vielleicht funktioniert ja dann davon
auch noch einer schade ist eigentlich
dass ich meinen eigenen shop lucky luke
punkt.de verändert sich neutral den habe
ich nicht mehr den habe ich abgeben dann
gibt es noch aber ist nicht mein job
sonst hätte ich die fernseher
theoretisch auch darüber verkaufen
können ich habe mir darüber die letzten
zwei jahre auch selber echt viel wissen
angeeignet aber das coole ist man muss
nicht gar nicht mehr alles selber
aneignen es gibt ja im internet super
super viele tutorial unter anderem auch
auf skills und was es da alles gibt und
was euch das bringt das zeige ich euch
jetzt macht so leute wir befinden uns
jetzt hier gerade auf skill schert das
ist einfach eine online learning
plattform mit ganz ganz vielen
verschiedenen kategorien möchte dass man
kurz vorstellen und zeigen warum das
gerade auch für mich interessant ist und
ich glaube für sehr viele von euch da
draußen auch ich denke mal die meisten
von euch ja mitbekommen dass ich mich
persönlich sehr für riesling
interessiere und ich denke mal durch die
videos die ich mache gibt es auch einige
von euch da draußen die das thema ganz
interessant finden wenn es dann zum
beispiel darum geht seinen eigenen
online-shop zu starten den ersten
eigenen online shop ist skater auf jeden
fall eine interessante plattform ihr
habt ja allein schon 137 verschiedene
videos und kurse zum thema shopping fall
ganz einfach der hier ist super
interessant shops vvs zeit da wird alles
erklärt ganze video anschauen und dann
aber auch so die themenbereiche skippen
dieser kurs ist jetzt beispielsweise
sogar auf deutsch das ist ganz gut es
gibt allerdings auch viele kurse die
sind auf englisch film und video auch
ganz interessant ich meine ich musste
eigentlich nicht mehr viel lernen aber
man kann nie auslernen das ist das ding
eine cut pro damit schneide ich schon
ganz ganz lange
ihr könnt jetzt hier zum beispiel sehen
dass videos auf englisch aber ganz easy
untertitel an machen hier und dann kann
man da auch alles verstehen hier oben
unterkategorien es gibt wirklich
unfassbar viel es geht von grafik design
gestalten illustrieren musik fotografie
bis zu auch wirklich geschäftlichen
themen man hat der geschäftsanalyse drin
ja marketing also man kann sich das geld
wirklich enorm weiterbilden oder auch
wenn ihr einfach denke ich möchte
unbedingt noch einmal meinen beruf
wechseln ich möchte freiberufler werden
oder sonst was dann ist gilt ja wirklich
eine super interessante plattform für
euch egal ob jetzt irgendwas von grund
auf neu erlernen wollt oder schon profi
der fortgeschrittene seit man kann ja
auch ganz einfach anfänger auswählen
oder dann halt irgendwie doch auch
fortgeschritten auch die länge der kurse
könnt ihr definieren abschließend auch
ganz wichtig wenn ihr jetzt noch nicht
zu hundert prozent überzeugt seid ihr
könnt das ganze natürlich auch erst mal
kostenlos testen jack scannell ausbilder
euch weiter und werdet einfach
freiberufler und wir machen jetzt weiter
nicht im video let's go home shopping
kurs zurück zum philips fernseher 1 und
2 und 3 kommt also ich finds geil wenn
wir jetzt mal nicht der bildschirm
gesplittet ist wobei dann hat auch
gesagt manchmal kostet allein schon so
eine fernbedienung 50 euro und das hier
ist wirklich eine tolle familie jetzt
zeige ich euch mal dass ich diesen
fernseher auch alleine auspacken kann
sieht wieder echt toll aus übrigens als
die fernseher heute morgen ankamen haben
direkt zur fünf leute auf der straße zu
mir weil die stand kurz auf der straße
halten krasse fernseher wo hast du her
wie teuer wie teuer kann ich einkaufe
ich so beruhigt euch und wir werden
wahrscheinlich alle nicht funktionieren
das ist auch so vorsichtig
ich sehe hier noch keine spuren kommen
bitte egal hier ist nix also wenn der
angeht lasst uns jetzt einfach noch so
schrauben
es ist so dumm leute der wird
funktionieren mit ansage und wenn der
funktioniert der kostet 800 euro ist
alles gut ist das wohl noch nie geöffnet
wurde jetzt öffentlich gerade aber wir
beten singen rein tut sich was ich
komplett an ohne störungen oder bei der
sec hat angegangen oder batterien sind
auch drin
so der
macht komische geräusche oder leute drei
zu eins an
anbei geht an unten
ja es an netflix netflix
ist wieder ein flop oder es funktioniert
halt leider nur der an und aus knopf
aber es ist nicht ersichtlich dass
irgendwo der display gestört ist das
heißt wer geht wahrscheinlich keinen
großen schaden haben so wie ich musste
es überprüfen lassen keine ahnung
vielleicht geht er ja noch an wilders
den einfach mal so ok drei von 32 sind
definitiv defekt einer hat sicherlich
nur einen leichteren kleinen defekt
drauf was macht ausbeute bis jetzt
ausbaufähig wieder alles top alles
wunderbar vorsichtig jetzt habe ich auch
händchen für fernseher aus verpackungen
raus ist was mit sieht gut aus oder
was hat er
es blickt warum der ist doch eh kaputt
was soll ich machen der hat ja einen
absoluten schaden hier ist sogar noch
eine folie drauf und das display ist
aber bedeutet so ein action an
und
weil man nur hier oben während da oben
da
[Musik]
aber man kann ja ein bisschen was er
kann wir machen fortschritte guck mal
mama
ist vielleicht ganz kurz dazu ich gehe
mal ganztag davon aus dass diese
fernseher auch sicherlich irgendwo schon
mal zwischen geschickt wurden und dann
gesagt wurde okay damit kann man
wirklich nichts mehr anfangen und wir
verkaufen jetzt für 35 euro das stück
weiter oder noch weniger ich habe
allerdings letztens auch mal fernseher
gesehen in life die auch im
retourenlager waren die auch relativ
günstig waren die wohl nur so kleine
defekte hatten bis vor der rest aber
noch funktioniert hat das wäre
vielleicht auch mal interessant aber ich
will jetzt nicht den teufel an die wand
mal bei den größten haben wir ja noch
wenn der funktioniert der kostet auf
jeden fall über 1500 euro staaten krieg
nicht alleine hier aus kann man schwitzt
hier schon ne das ist ein riesen
fernseher fan wirklich das hui auch die
plötzlich 40
und jetzt müsst ihr das nur hochziehen
vorsichtig nein nein passen auf dass wir
nicht
gekippt gar nix
alter ist das ein riesen fernseher also
hier geht zwar ganz gut
da ist defekt oder doch da
ich dachte ich habe es elf glück die
leute da kann man es ganz gut sehen auch
der fernseher ist leider kaputt aber er
ist trotzdem safe noch mehr wert als 530
euro das würde ich mal behaupten wegen
den ganzen sachen die da drin sind und
so auch ja leute wir werden das ganze
jetzt mal wieder zusammenpacken ich bin
sehr gespannt auf eure kommentare ich
werde natürlich trotzdem in der
zwischenzeit das ganze mal so ja so ein
fachmann fragen wie man fernseher
repariert ob sich das lohnt einfach
davon aus dass sich nicht lohnen wird
ich habe es trotzdem mal versucht und
das ist jetzt das ergebnis ich hoffe ihr
hattet halbwegs spannung beim schauen
ich bin wirklich davon ausgegangen oder
ich habe gehofft da werden safe
fernsehen funktionieren oder vielleicht
kriegt da irgendwie die fernbedienung
fehlen da weil sie nicht jetzt allem
schaden haben bis auf den einen da habe
ich noch hoffnung drin aber irgendwas
ist damit ja auch es wird auf jeden fall
noch eine fortsetzung zum fernseh
projekt geben und ich werde euch dann
ein paar weitere infos dazu mitteilen
gegenseite angespannt aber und jetzt
sobald in den kanal rembrandts kirche
abzuchecken sehr sehr interessante kurse
dort vorhandenen für jedermann 1000
leute
also schon super